تتزحم لوحات المشاريع الاغاثيه للنازحين
في احد اكبر تجمعاتهم بمارب
والمعاناه مستمره في مخيم السويداء غربي
المحافظه لا يختلف الحال كثيرا عن بقيه
تجمعات النزول
مع اشتداد موجه البردي تزداد المخاوف من
تسجيل حالات وفيات جديده من الاطفال وكبار
السن في خيام مهترئه مزقتها الرياح
يعانون كثيرا من شده البرد النازحون ما
فيه الا عيدان وترابيل يصلحونها نريد نريد
حلول جذريه النازحين في هذا المخيم يوجدوا
لنا همم مخيمات حلوه جدا كراتير حلول
جذريه بحيث نازح همم يحصل ماوى ضمه اولاده
تحاول النسوه بعد ان فقدنا ازواجهن في
الحرب جمعه اغصان الاشجار ثم تغطيتها
بالترابيل والاقمشه في محاوله لتوفير مسكن
امن لابنائهن يقيهم موجه البرد القارس
فيما ام ياسر التي حصلت على احدى الخيام
تجهز بيديها ماده الاسمنت لتسد الفجوات
التي تتسلل منها الرياح البارده وهكذا
الحال من التجهيزات البسيطه للنازحين في
ظل غياب المسكن الملائم لطبيعه المنطقه
وظروف النزوح
ها معرش رجليها لها كذا واحد جنب واحد جنب
واحد علشان يدخله وسطه كل يوم نسوي
البطانيه وتكمل بطانيه وتقطع من الشمس من
الرياح ونرجع ثاني وعلى هذا برد عسل
شبكه
ونشتري نسدد على نفوسنا هكذا
دافيه
عرضتها المنظمات الاغاثيه واقرتها كتله
الماوى وواحده النازحين في مارب العام
الماضي لكنها لم تصل للنازحين الى اليوم
الشتاء قاسم على النازحين في مارب لذا
يحاولون تامين مساكنه تقيهم واطفالهم موجه
البرد القادمه من اعواد الاشجار محمود
الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب